european union finance and economy
ministers have broken off talks on new
measures to preempt bank crises but plan
to meet again on december 18 to try to
seal a deal by the end of the year
the eco-fin council wants to agree the
terms to establish a single
decision-making authority the so-called
single resolution mechanism and a single
fund to help banks under pressure
we have no formal results in our pocket
or on the table
but we made a huge leap forward
defining the
concrete directions and concrete schemes
that can be further quite
immediately adjusted and discussed with
the
experts of the member states and then
presented
put on the table of the continuation of
the echo finn next week
positions on the proposals a key part of
the eu's ambitious banking union will be
narrowed down by experts ahead of the
december 18 meeting
the aim is to help a struggling credit
institution or investment firm recover
from any shock in an orderly manner
preserving its operations and minimizing
the possibility of taxpayer losses
the measures must be agreed by the
european parliament so eu nations want
to move the package forward before the
assembly's legislative term ends in may
the ministers also sought to reach a
political agreement on rules governing
savings taxation but austria and
luxembourg maintain their reservations
over the proposals which can only be
adopted unanimously
the measures are meant to help fight tax
evasion and tax fraud the council will
report to eu leaders that the proposals
cannot be adopted by the deadline that
they've set